now we come to the
audience-participation part of our
program ladies and gentlemen a chance
for those of you who are at home to play
the game would you like to win an Oscar
it's easy you don't have to learn the
mumble you don't have to change your
psychiatrist just take dancing lessons I
mean look at the past winners just about
half of them a hoofers who turned honest
Jimmy Cagney John Crawford Fred Astaire
and Gene Kelly and then of course the
new crowd George Chakiris
Rita Moreno Audrey Hepburn they all
started out as dancers and of course the
most prominent example of them all to
give the music scoring Awards the
Academy Award winner for Kitty Foyle
miss Ginga Raja
as Frank hidden music does have a little
something to do with my career and for
that reason I am pleased to present the
achievement awards for music scoring the
nominees for the best music score
substantially original nominations are
Jerry Goldsmith for Freud Maurice Jarre
for Lawrence of Arabia branislav keeper
for mutiny on the bounty from Waxman for
Tereshkova Elmer Bernstein for To Kill a
Mockingbird the anvil clean the winner
maurice for the race
excepting for Maurice Jarrah mr. Morris
stole off
I'm not Maury Shar I was coordinated for
the music Lawrence of Arabia but in his
absence I would like to thank Motion
Picture Academy 20 pictures mr. Sam
Spiegel David Lee for this honor I'm
sure he'd be very happy and very
grateful very much
the nominees for the best scoring of
music adaptation and treatment are
George stole for Billy roses jumbo
Michel mang for Eagle Frank Perkins for
gypsy ray hind or for Meredith Willson's
The Music Man Lee Harleen for the
wonderful world of the Brothers Grimm
the winner
thank you very much and thank you
the next award will be for Best
Supporting Actor
hollywood's does